hello and thank you for joining us today
my name is cody magnesi i'm product
manager for gk and today i would like to
share with you some of the best
practices on how to leverage gke to
power a competitive i.t e-commerce
infrastructure
first let's start with looking at some
of the drivers for e-commerce
organization and the requirements they
imply for the supporting infrastructure
in a recent validation study of google
cloud solution for e-commerce the esg
analysis found that retail industry is
focused on providing better and more
differentiated customer experience
through specifically digital
transformation initiatives with about 50
percent of retail organization
strategically prioritizing this
objective
for retailers creating an e-commerce
presence
increase not just the touch points with
the customer but also the sales
opportunity especially when event like
the pandemic pushes more customers to
online channels at the same times it
also increase the competitive landscape
to maintain the competitiveness an
e-commerce infrastructure must provide
one high performance two scalability
three reliability and availability
for
customization and innovation and finally
flexibility
let's look deeper into these areas to
understand how kubernetes and gke
address these areas we will also provide
some recommendation for configuration
and options that you would want to
consider for your cluster
many customers use gcp to migrate
modernize and improve their deployments
gcp infrastructure and networking are
powering gke so when you create a
kubernetes cluster on gke
we provision the machine and the
resources needed for
gke to properly run your clusters
control plane and nodes on gcp
the kubernetes cluster control plane is
fully managed by us backed by an sla we
will keep the control plane up to date
and will scale it automatically up and
down when cluster size changes
for efficiency and high performance you
can choose what type of machine what
machine configuration best meets your
needs for your different node pools
and as demands changes over time so does
the load on your ecommerce workloads
scaling is necessary to ensure that gke
grows to match your need think about
number of pods number of nodes
gk includes several auto scaling
capabilities that will automatically
resize your cluster based on your
configuration
and signals that we monitor
hpa for example automatically increases
or decreases the number of pods on your
cluster based on utilization
with vpa and npa you can enable vertical
scale for both your nodes and pods
and if capacity planning is part of your
practice especially for peak season like
black friday cyber monday or new year
you may want to reserve gc capacity
with gc reservation when your gk cluster
requires to scale repair or upgrade it
will have a reserved pool of dedicated
resources available for for the
performance
you can also create specific or
non-specific reservation and gk will
create new resources based on the pool
that you reserved
now let's talk about availability and
it's it's important to distinguish
between application availability and
infrastructure availability
the availability of the business
application which the customers interact
with and the availability availability
of the
infrastructure which hosts and support
the application
on the application side the impact of
insufficient availability can be
unresponsive e-commerce website or
unreachable service on the
infrastructure side the impact can
happen at different levels
at the cluster level for example when
nodes become unresponsive or when pods
get rescheduled at zone level or at
regional level where there is a
connectivity issue for example
while both the application and the
infrastructure impacts the overall
availability it is actually the business
application that drives the decision
around redundancy deployments and
architecture
with this definition in mind it is
important to understand how gke
structure as a shared responsibility
product the data plane the nodes where
the e-commerce workloads are deployed
are the most critical piece for
customers
as any reliability issue can directly
impact the business
the kubernetes control plane is the next
most critical piece as it's responsible
for scaling repairing managing the
deployments um and then most of the
workloads deployed on the data plane can
probably survive
an outage a short outage of the control
plane without too much impact
the gk control plane on the leftmost
side is the least critical piece as they
are mainly focused on the operations and
the management of the gk control plane
next let's look on the two most
important pieces uh from a reliability
perspective
both control planes and nodes can be
provisioned in a single zone a zonal
cluster
as illustrated on the right side or can
be provisioned in three different zones
within a region a regional cluster
there are some cases where zona cluster
topology
better serve your needs
and constraints we do recommend however
to use regional cluster for highly
available kubernates infrastructure
especially for production workloads
for control planes the redundancy
provide high availability and in turn
provide higher sla for the kubernetes
api
but besides of the api availability
um
the api availability in the control pin
doesn't really impact the workloads
themselves necessarily the control pane
is also responsible for maintaining the
cluster with scaling repairing and other
vital operations and you may want to
take into consideration based on the
nature of your ecommerce workloads and
needs the type of topology that is right
for your architecture
since we provision compute resources on
gcp for the kubernetes clusters node
availability are based on the compute
engine availability for instances
provisioned in a single or multiple
zones
finally the availability of your
applications is closely tied to the node
availability as you can imagine and
luckily kubernetes offers an easy way to
create multiple instances of your
application for higher availability
one great way to secure higher
availability for your application and
also to reduce potential disruption is
the use of pdb or
port disruption budget
pdb allows you to state your
disruption's tolerance in other words if
your application is replicated
you can specify the minimum number of
replicas that can be disrupted when
maintenance even happens
in the example that i have on the slide
here on the right side we specify that
we cannot tolerate less than two
replicas of our application this is just
another way of saying max unavailable
equal one in case we have three replicas
of the application
gk respects pdb up to 60 minutes and
termination grace policy up to 60
minutes
when a security patch or kubernetes
update is rolled out on your cluster gke
will perform the upgrade in a way that
satisfy the pdb configuration
the other thing that you want gke to
know about your workloads is what
consideration it needs to apply when it
scheduled your codes on different nodes
in the cluster
by default gke and the kubernetes
scheduler automatically spreads your
pods across the nodes
whether it's regional or zona cluster
however some e-commerce application and
specifically stateful workloads like
redis for example require a quorum of
servers to successfully work in a
redundant deployment
without specific instruction kubernetes
may decide to collocate all the pods for
your stateful application stateful set
on the same machine on the same node and
basically
create a single point of failure and
risk of to that availability of the
e-commerce application
exactly for those reasons we can use por
anti-affinity to ensure pods are not
scheduled on the same specific node if
we set the criteria so if i require a
quorum of servers to properly operate a
stateful application for example i would
want kubernetes to refrain from
scheduling all the replicas on the same
machine so if something happened to that
machine
it won't it take down all the different
replicas of my application
on the flip side there are some
applications workloads that may actually
benefit from being collocated on the
same machine for example if you have a
web server and you want to co-locate it
with a cache service for better
performance and lower latency in this
case you might want to use
pod affinity
another important aspect of the
infrastructure reliability is monitoring
and specifically providing accurate
signals to kubernetes about your
workload state and health
the first
signal in this slide
is readiness probe which basically
defines a signal for when a workload is
ready to serve traffic
say for example if a workload takes some
time to start the lack of such signal
may lead to kubernetes starting to send
traffic to a not yet ready-to-response
workload
which will lead to time-out and impacted
experience
the second
signal here is liveness prob which
provides a health signal that kubernetes
use to determine whether it should
initiate a repair and replace of a
faulty instance or not
defining an upgrade strategy for your
cluster is another important dimension
of reliability a new kubernetes miner
version is released roughly every four
months from open source
and patched versions are released more
frequently
because the kubernetes clusters contains
both control plane and nodes there are
two places to manage when it comes to
keeping your
clusters up to date with releases
security patches and bug fixes
luckily gke offers different ways to
keep your cluster's infrastructure up to
date
being a shared responsibility product gk
keeps control plane automatically
updated and alternatively you can keep
your node version upgraded automatically
or initiated the upgrade manually
by running your own script or using our
api
to ensure that your infrastructure is up
to date and and also being kept as such
in a safe and non-disruptive way we
highly recommend the use of multiple
environments so when there is a new
version or a patch um it can roll it can
be rolled out for testing and
qualification on staging and
testing environments before it hits the
production environment
in general we recommend to use the same
version in all environments so you get
consistency and
correctness of your qualification
process
however you may want to consider a
second development environment where
newer releases can be tested this can be
useful when a new gke feature or
kubernetes api are being introduced and
you want to test them
to get a head start and be ready for the
market
when you have a new feature that rely on
this capability
the process of upgrading your kubernetes
clusters you know keeping the control
plane and nodes preferably in sync when
it comes to the same version and also in
a supported version
and also in a supported version skew
that is mandated by open source
that process can be totally and very
cumbersome and one way to simplify it is
by using release channel radius channel
in gke allows you to choose your upgrade
path
and also control the type of upgrade
that
will be applied on your cluster
some customers may want to use the
latest kubernetes version because as i
mentioned before dependencies on a new
api or capability
or maybe they have specific business
objective in this case you may want to
use the rapid channel
which is closer to open source in terms
of releases
other customers may prefer stability
over functionality
and in that case they would choose
either the stable channel or the regular
channel which are the ones we recommend
for production workloads
when it comes to patching or upgrading
your cluster the nodes where the
e-commerce application are deployed
we replace them those nodes are being
replaced with new provision machine
running the the newer kubernetes cheeky
version when an upgrade takes place
when nodes are replaced as you can
imagine pods running on them are
gracefully shut down so the node can be
trained and replaced
on the gke side node upgrade used to
follow the workflow of delete then
create meaning that when we upgrade gke
used to drain
a node delete it and then replace it
with a new one however to increase the
availability and also to reduce
disruption node upgrade is now happening
through surge upgrade where we change
actually the order
we first create a new node for the
upgrade and only when that node is ready
and available we gracefully drain the
old node not only that surge reduced
disruption to existing nodes it also
allows you to control the number of node
of nodes that can be upgraded currently
the default setting is one node at a
time so keep that in mind if you are
using large
clusters with many nodes you probably
want to change
that number so more nodes can be
concurrently upgraded
at the same time it is clear that
sustaining a competitive e-commerce
infrastructure requires a continuous
upgrade practice
however as we all know sometimes
business requirements may change
especially when disruption simply cannot
be tolerated
for example you know think about peak
seasons like black fighter submarine
monday new year or major company events
trade fairs or something like that
we recommend you to use
exclusion window for this event with
exclusion window you can specify a range
of dates in which you want to refrain
completely from any type of maintenance
you can also set up maintenance windows
to specify when you prefer maintenance
to happen this can help you to improve
predictability of the upgrade and also
allow the to control the time of the
upgrade on different clusters
exclusion windows and maintenance
windows can
greatly help you control the disruption
and reduce risk
but we've seen with many retail
customers
that they are actually experiencing
different requirements during different
time of their fiscal year for example an
e-commerce infrastructure is most likely
to follow some regulation or compliance
like pci for example
and these compliance have specific
guidance when it comes to keeping your
software up to date and how frequent and
fast a new security patch should be
consumed
in this case i might want to allow all
type of upgrades and patches on both
control planes and nodes throughout a
low season month
while in during high peaking peak season
like black fighters on monday i want to
refrain completely from any type of
maintenance so my workloads will not be
affected
and then also in some other cases
i might be okay with just patching my
clusters both nodes and control planes
but would want to refrain from upgrading
to the next minor version
we believe that this level of
flexibility is actually needed for
e-commerce infrastructure
so they can control maintenance events
and also the risk level associated with
the change
in accordance to their business needs
this way you can delegate all patching
and upgrades to gk
while being able to instruct it on what
type of upgrades you want to allow the
scope and when to initiate a process
so now that we know how upgrades and
patches get rolled out
i think it's important to also stay
informed and know about changes coming
to your clusters
one place to learn about gk releases is
of course the gta release notes page
which includes you know links to
the release schedule and the version
support policy but we also recommend the
use of gk notification which includes
notification for upgrade and upgrade
available events gk notification
which is based on pub sub you can listen
to upgrade available events and which
when they fire indicate that there is a
newer version or patch available for for
your cluster
in turn you can use that event and
trigger a workflow to apply these
patches for example on your testing
cluster so the infrastructure version
can be vetted and qualified before it
gets released to your production
environment
finally a
robust e-commerce infrastructure must
also provide some flexibility so you can
apply some changes on the fly in a
non-disruptive way we've identified
several common places where changes
involve disruption because when you
apply these changes it actually requires
us to recreate the machine
or notepool
for example you may need to change
network tags in order to change firewall
rules or routes to your e-commerce
application
you can now do so you can change network
tags for existing running vms
without us recreating the vms and
basically applying this change on the
fly the same thing goes for no things
which you can use to steer away pods
from specific nodes or labels which are
used to schedule pods on particular
nodes
all these three options are now
modifiable without requiring recreation
of the machine
so we've learned from the esg report
that there are specific areas an
e-commerce infrastructure must cover to
maintain competitiveness
high availability where redundancy is
important to avoid single point of
failure
that applies to both control plane and
nodes
scalability
use multiple replicas the use of pdb to
avoid disruption
affinity and anti-affinity to better
instruct the kubernetes scheduler on how
to
optimize the deployment of your
workloads reliability and availability
remember that control planes are fully
managed
on gke and but can go through
maintenance
make sure that you don't create an
unnecessary dependencies on the control
plane api in your application to avoid
disruption to your application when
control plane is being upgraded
and then finally for flexibility there
are some changes that can be applied on
the slide and do not impose any
disruption for existing workloads
to close up i want to share a quote from
la blau a gke e-commerce customer who
achieved great success using both gcp
and gk despite going through the
unexpected challenges of the pandemic la
blanc migrated and modernized its
e-commerce with gcp ngk and also
leveraged the black fighter saba monday
white glove service for additional peace
of mind during this critical business
period
this resulted in better performance at
scale faster application development and
deployment high availability and
elimination of black fighters our monday
outages
and while keeping the infrastructure up
to date la blanc managed to leverage the
different infrastructure capabilities to
roll out their kovit 19 vaccines
delivery system in nine weeks instead of
18 months
there's much more to learn you can
download the full esg report from the
first link on this page and find more
documentation best practices on the gke
website on the second link
thank you so much for watching this
session i hope you enjoy the rest of
your google next
you